monsieur girard bon jour en jour ce qui
va retenir l'attention beaucoup c'est ce
500 $ que vous retournez aux québécois
et ce qui retient mon attention en tout
cas c'est de voir une personne qui gagne
20 mille dards années pour pouvoir avoir
le sens de la une personne qui gagne 100
1000 par année va pouvoir aussi avoir le
500 dollars est ce qu'un poème iniquité
ici mais d'abord il faut regarder le
continuum de ce qu'on a fait on a fait
une compensation pour l'inflation en
2021 à l'automne pour les gens qui
gagnaient moins de 54 mille dollars
voilà où on a eu la compensation on a
aussi aidé les aînés de plus de 110 ans
à faible revenu alors il ya eu 7 est
justement là l'inflation est plus
persistantes en raison de l'invasion du
crâne par la russie et on a eu avec un
ajustement supplémentaire
basée sur un panier de consommation de
base alors si l'alimentation
l'habillement le transport le logement
et tout le monde est affecté par
l'inflation et c'est pour ça qu'on a
décidé oui mais c'est pour ça qu'on a
décidé de faire une mesure d'application
générale sur un panier de consommation
de base mais une famille par exemple un
couple deux fois 100 mille deux cent
mille dollars ils vont avoir 1000 $ est
ce que un coq qui donc 200 1000 par
année a besoin d'avoir un mille dollars
du gouvernement mais vous vous faites
référence est un cas particulier nous on
ne choisit et 6.8 millions de
contribuables on a tiré une ligne
c'était clair que ce que nous avions
fait à l'automne sera pour 3.3 millions
de personnes revenu moyen à faible
lenglen mesures d'application plus
générale on va jusqu à 6.4 millions de
personnes donc 94 % des québécois vont
recevoir le monde donc les gens à
faibles revenus vont recevoir le même
montant que les gens à plus forts
revenus c'est-à-dire qu'ils gagnent 100
mille tout le monde reçoit 500 $ et même
une personne par exemple faire cent dix
mille et qui à 15000 dents serrées air
son revenu net et 95 et hilal 500 $ et
louis mais là on est dans la définition
du 100 milles c'est effectivement la
ligne 2 175 rapports d et puis oui les
reér sont déduits est ce que cette
mesure là pour être répétée l'an
prochain si l'inflation demeure élevé je
pense que ce qu'on a on une situation
particulière on a eu au micron qui a
affecté du fait qu'il est extrêmement
contagieux affecté l'offre de
travailleurs et puis on voit que en asie
la chine notamment hong kong les grands
ports internationaux n'étaient pas prêts
pour le variant qui plus contagieux
alors donc lee alors qu'on attendait que
les goulots d'étranglement se desserre
ça ne s'est pas passé et à ça s'ajoute
la guerre que personne n'avait prévu et
donc on a de l'inflation mais au même
moment les banques centrales resserrent
les conditions monétaires et donc au
lieu de revenir à l'inflation à la fin
2022 ce sera 2020 tout en ignorant une
indexation du régime fiscal pour 2023 et
on verra où nous en sommes avec les
objets de tous et l'inflation on verra
et on verra pour les tarifs
d'électricité aussi parce que dans les
livres et d'électricité ce qu'on a dit
c'est que lorsque le projet de loi a été
déposé nous avions prévu nous observions
que historiquement l'inflation était
toujours à l'intérieur des bancs de la
banque centrale en un et trois pour ça
leur situation exceptionnelle on est
au-delà de 3% est ce que le premier
ministre dit et ce sur quoi on travaille
il y aura des annonces prochainement
c'est s'assurer de ne point puisqu'on
n'avait pas prévu cette situation
exceptionnelle c'est qu'heuliez pas de
chauffage pourquoi c'est pas dans ce
budget c'est pendant le budget parce que
c'est la responsabilité du ministre de
l'énergie des ressources naturelles il
on travaille sur une solution sûre
budgétaire donc ça va être un montant
qui va être tourné aux québécois en
jeune je n'annonce pas aujourd'hui la
forme si j'avais la forme je leur ai mis
le budget ben oui c'est ça mais question
de prévisibilité pourquoi on le sait pas
parce que l'on s'en va vers une hausse
tarifaire de
fer et de 2.6 pour ça on avait les bars
je suis même allé delahousse en 2020
exactement la hausse le 1er avril 2000
22,2 points 6% et première 2003
pourraient à est au-delà de 5% en fait
notre prévision on le dit dans le budget
elle pourrait excéder 5% et son
ministre on sent bien une chose mais
cette zone volkov je vous demande ça
sera pas le cas comment vous allez mais
se faire en sorte que ce soit pas le cas
on travaille sur la solution elle sera
divulgué lorsqu'elle est entendu en
temps et lieu
pourquoi il n'a pas de baisses d'impôts
pour les entreprises parce que les
entreprises aussi sont frappés par
l'inflation notamment sur les carburants
les entreprises ont le fait plusieurs
jeux on a amené là ce qu'on fait depuis
nous sommes nous voir c'est réduire le
taux effectif d'imposition sur les
nouveaux investissements
l'amortissement accéléré le c3 et alors
là vous voyez qu'on a prolongé le
le fait que nous avons doublé le tout
crédit sur le crédit d'impôt wallis
alors si ça l'est jusqu'aux pause on a
baissé aussi les impôts des pme aux
précédents budgets alors c'est la
chambre des gestes depuis nous sommes au
pouvoir on a réduit le taux effectif
marginal d'imposition sur les nouveaux
inscrits les entreprises n'ont pas à
bénéficier en ce moment d'une aide
supplémentaire même s'ils doivent même
s'ils sont frappés par l'inflation
particulièrement sur le carburant on n'a
pas jugé que fallait faire cet
ajustement est en fait on a eu plusieurs
consultations les consultations
prébudgétaires on ne s'est pas fait
demander de compensation
en vertu de l'inflation par les
entreprises vous dites que c'est un
budget responsable et très prudent
tellement prud'hommes avec les
provisions puis avec l'argent qui est un
des signatures dans la copie de cet
absolu mans nécessaire mais si je prends
la provision l'aco vide et le fonds des
générations j'enlève ça on est a dit
qu'il est budgétaire dans les faits mais
a fait au québec on a une définition de
l' équilibre budgétaire qui est
extrêmement rigoureuse après
contribution au fonds numération si nous
utilisions la même définition que le
gouvernement canadien ou les autres
provinces où nous serions à l'équilibré
en 2023 24 c'est à des avants
conscription frangine donc ça vous donne
la marge de manoeuvre pour baisser les
impôts des québécois c'est à 10 clos le
budget ce que de la situation actuelle
on a une urgence l'inflation on a besoin
de rétablir notre système de santé ont
fourni les fonds pour l'on donne les
moyens aux mines et de la santé faire le
rétablissement du système de santé aussi
sur les priorités actuelles la
productivité 2 milliards 200 millions
sur cinq ans pour la productivité des
entreprises la prévision de croissance
économique à partir de 2024 et à 1.5
pour ça je pense que c'est en en dessous
de votre objectif on n'atteindra pas les
objectifs de productivité converse mais
c'est à dire que comme économiste faut
toujours faire la distinction entre ce
qu'on veut accomplir est ce que ce qu'on
peut mettre dans un cadre financier qui
prudent alors dès qu'on dépasse
l'horizon 18 mois 2 ans on doit s'en
remettre aux taux de croissance à long
terme de l'économie actuellement
celui-ci est estimé à 1.5 pour centre
c'est ce qu'on mène encore financiers
c'est certain qu'on vit plus que ça
roulait vers où il nous a baissé de
rabais
relation de 8000 7000 parce que les
coûts de production des voitures
électriques baisse tout ça mais en même
temps on est dans un monde où il faut
tellement de façon urgente faire la
transition vers les véhicules
électriques
il ya des objectifs haussiers blake est
ce que ce pas un message contraire que
vous envoyer en versant mais le rabais
puisque l'objectif c'est d'atteindre nos
cibles de réduction de gaz à effet de
serre on a dit c'est très ambitieuse 5 %
en 2030
le québec n'a jamais atteint ses cibles
nous à chaque année on fait un plan de
mise en oeuvre on était à 42% l'objet on
l on ajoute un milliard ont plein de
mise en oeuvre tu vas être divulguées
par le ministre en vironnement il faut
se rapproche et leurs boissons les
rabais sur les tarifs ont sur les choix
du jury on ajoute des bornes il les prix
et la demande est très forte les
voitures écrit donc le le rabais a
toujours été fonction du différentiel
entre les voitures à essence les
voitures électriques on est cohérent là
dessus mais ça va permettre de libérer
des centres pour d'autres actions on
vient à réduire les gaz à effet de serre
parce que c'est ça l'objectif
voilà merci monsieur girard merci
beaucoup merci pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit